well guys if you happen to have really
loved the Resident Evil version for the
Gamecube like myself there is a new
version of it in HD glorious 1080p
resolution out now for purchase on a
wide variety of places for only $19.99
and I was like that's a perfect deal I'm
going to buy this now and I played it
and oh my goodness gracious why does
this game still give me goosebumps I'm a
huge Resident Evil fan I've loved almost
all of the games not quite all of them
some of the newer ones weren't that
great that being said I did really enjoy
Resident Evil Revelations and I of
course love Resident Evil 4 and I even
liked Resident Evil 0 for goodness sakes
I have a Resident Evil 2 magnet on my
fridge yeah I'm that guy so playing this
new version and wonderous 1080p HD was a
marvelous experience for me as a huge
fan I love the changes they made as well
because there are some basic changes
made to the gameplay nothing too big
just little tiny things that actually
enhance the experience in a very
positive way now in case you're one of
the few people who never had the chance
to play the original Resident Evil game
in this game you can choose between
playing as Chris who I never play as
despite the fact that he has my name I
always play as Jill Valentine you are in
a mansion a very deserted creepy ass
mansion and an outbreak has occurred and
you have to investigate why this
outbreak has taken place this is not
just a game which zombies burst out of
doors and you blow off their heads this
is a puzzle game this is a stealth game
this is a game which you have to
investigate things and figure stuff out
on your own it is a very psychological
game and that's what I love about
Resident Evil sure the fourth
installment in the series was a lot of
fun it added a new action element to the
series but I have always preferred
entering a creepy empty room picking up
books reading manuscripts that you've
found discovering clues and figuring
things out for yourself one of the
creepiest things about this game for me
still to this day
you can walk up to just about anything
press X and you get a little text of
what your character is thinking or what
she is looking at and it's always like
something rific aliy disturbing like
look at this painting filled with
decapitated heads and that aspect of
this game for whatever reason still
gives me chills to this day no idea why
it just does HD graphics are wondrous I
love them my eyes that like to examine
things like that and make sure that the
clarity is there they're just they're
happy right now when I watch this game
they're just so overjoyed to see it in
HD present evil in HD it's such a
wonderful thing and there are some new
things to this game for one there's a
new added control scheme that you can
choose to have or you can play in its
original form in which you use the
control stick and you are always running
you don't have to make your character
run you move left and right with the
control stick and you're always running
and you can continuously keep it moving
in the same direction as you change
angles unlike in the original there is a
widescreen mode in this game in which
they have incorporated very minut pan
and scan which may annoy some people and
if it does you can choose to play it in
the original 4 by 3 aspect ratio so
that's awesome I love that about this
game they're not forcing you to play it
in the 16 by 9 if you want to play it in
the original you can if you have never
had the chance to play the original
Resident Evil this is the best option
you have for the best graphics for the
best HD experience and for the best
control scheme it's only $20 it's on a
ton of different platforms right now I
strongly strongly suggest downloading it
I had a great time with Resident Evil HD
and since I'm such a huge fan of this
game and since they gave you the
original control scheme in the original
aspect ratio if you want to stay that
way I can't find anything I don't adore
about this game I'm given Resident Evil
HD a 10 out of 10 guys i really suggest
checking it out also if you guys are
curious about what my most anticipated
games of 2015 are i recently did a live
google hangout with Maude Garrett of
geek balm and you can view that on her
youtube channel this is a super super
hard-working woman she's really cool and
she's really talented she goes to e3 she
does
all this stuff she gets into all this
crazy stuff that I'm so envious and
jealous about but definitely go and give
her a subscription if you can and check
out that video we both discuss our most
anticipated games of 2015 the link for
that video is in the description below
and thank you to christopher Wade from
spark flow Studios for making that
incredibly awesome game intro for me I
am very grateful sir thank you very much
guys thank you so much as always for
watching I'm super excited also to bring
you my first episode of retro rewind all
about Toonami very soon I'm going to
have a couple celebrity guests on there
I'm so excited to bring out to you guys
I've honestly never had more fun making
a video and it's the video I'm most
proud of for that very soon as always
thank you so much guys and if you like
this you can click right here and get
stuck mine eyes